[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique le 11
mai prochain les élus locaux auront la
possibilité de mettre en oeuvre le plan
de déconfinement dure du gouvernement
la plupart ont déjà pris les devants
pour parler à certaines carences du
pouvoir motivation sanitaires ou
politique
on va le voir les maires et les
collectivités font-ils mieux que l'état
c'est la question du débat ce soir nous
sommes avec aurélie gros conseiller
régional d'ile-de-france et présidente
de la france vraiment efface avoue
georges kuzmanovic fondateur de
république souveraine
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france cette semaine
beaucoup de mères continuent donc de
réclamer le port du masque obligatoire
dans l'espace public à partir du 11 mai
écoutez ce qu'on dit christophe castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur et on en
parle juste après c'est à la fois pas
cohérent par rapport à l'exigence
qu'implique le confinement parce que ça
peut laisser penser qu'on peut sortir et
c'est aussi un sujet d'égalité
territoriales parce que certaines
communes peuvent avoir les moyens
d'équiper l'ensemble de leur population
en masque quand d'autres ne l'aurait pas
aurélie gros la question des masques a
dit viser un profondément là elle a
entre la doctrine du gouvernement et
celles de certains maires qu'est ce que
ça révèle du bras de fer qui a eu lieu
pendant cette crise sanitaire
je crois qu'il faut d'une part il faut
pas jeter la pierre ou au gouvernement
sans cesse en disant que le gouvernement
n'a pas fait son travail il a essayé de
faire son travail correctement
mais il se bat avec une belle énergie
mais je pense qu'il a eu à faire face à
une technostructure déconnecté de la
réalité ce que les mères au quotidien ne
sont ne sont pas confrontés à ce genre
de problématique et jeu quand on voit
l'exemple du directeur de la rs
du grand est qui a voulu retirer des
lits fermés dry en pleine épidémie ça
montre bien que la déconnexion totale de
ces grandes administrations parisiennes
qu'ils connaissent pas le terrain et
aujourd'hui les pairs font face à sète
cette problématique de l'état qui
voudraient s'intéresser aux territoires
mais qu'il peut pas le faire sans se
connecter aux collectivités
territoriales donc aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut plus avoir à un couple état
collectivités territoriales et non pas
un état qui rejette sur la collectivité
territoriale tout le poids de cette
pandémie en termes de gestion est
clairement les communes font face mais
il ya aussi les départements il ya aussi
les régions qu'on fait face on a vu la
région ile-de-france a pu fournir un
grand nombre de mâle ce que à ces
professionnels de santé il ya eu mille
masques par pharmacie données pour les
patients que l'état n'était pas capable
de faire il ya eu la distribution en
gare plus toutes les aides diverses et
variées aux entreprises qui ont été
données par la région et ça montre que
cette ce couple état collectivités
territoriales est nécessaire en france
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on
arrive à avoir un âge adulte en termes
décentralisation haut niveau au niveau
de la france
aujourd'hui on était dans quelque chose
où on voulait avoir un état qui
centralise et tout en en laissant de
côté cette décentralisation qui est
nécessaire on l'a vu pour d'autres
raisons dans la dans la crise des gilets
jaunes ce manque d' écoute et je crois
que cette crise
c'est une leçon est que cette grise doit
permettre de revoir cette danse
décentralisation et la rend beaucoup
plus mature et beaucoup plus adulte en
france
il faut s'appeler sur les collectivités
territoriales il faut s'appuyer sur les
communes
il faut s'appuyer sur les départements
et les règes vous parlez de maturité
aurélie gros art on a vu il ya eu des
bagarres avec la réquisition notamment
de certains masques par le gouvernement
que les régions avaient pu obtenir
qu'est ce que ça révèle georges kiejman
au beach est ce que l'état et les
collectivités
son concurrent ou sont complémentaires
selon vous c'est le président françois
mitterrand qui disait qu'il y a 2
pouvoir politique en france il ya celui
du président de la république
et puis il ya celui des mères et que
tous les autres sont des sortes de
masques là alors moi je ne serais pas
d'accord avec avec aurélie mais ce
gouvernement une responsabilité colossal
comme le fond repart a remarqué non pas
des politiques mais des soignants encore
récemment dans une lettre de la quasi
totalité des organisations de médecins
de france
on peut penser bien sûr au masque au
manque de réactivité alors qu'on avait
un coup d'avancé en voyant tout ce qui
se passait en chine chez nos voisins
italiens
tout ça était largement dit mais la
responsabilité principale
elle vient d'autre chose c'est que ce
gouvernement est un gouvernement qui a
excellent un excellent fichiers que
c'est dans sa tête qui en continu en
flux tendu qui a toujours appliqué les
exigences de lieux de casse des services
publics il a montré pendant un an avant
alors qu'il y avait des révoltes de
médecins que les soignants se poser à
ces politiques qui les a ignorés pendant
un an
il demandait quoi je vous le rappelle
plus de moyens plus de lits d'hôpitaux
plus de meilleurs salaires
bonrepaux d'un gouvernement qui se
caractérise par une irresponsabilité
absolue est parfaite responsabilités ou
transfert régulièrement la
responsabilité de ses décisions au
conseil scientifique et maintenant il le
fait au maire il le fait d'ailleurs aux
parents ce qui est aussi une honte
inacceptable cirque il responsabilise
les parents alors que ça serait du rôle
de gouvernement de dire on peut ou on ne
peut pas nous avons des pays voisins où
l'école par exemple a été reportée en
septembre
je pense à l'espagne à l'italie la moité
des pays scandinaves de facto en grande
bretagne parce qu'ils disent qu'ils vont
y réfléchir en jouant l'année scolaire
est évidemment fini on voit que le 11
mai visiblement été choisi de la même
manière avec la même responsabilité que
le maintien des élections du premier
tour et face à cela les maires se
retrouve avec des agents ctions
quasiment impossible à réaliser
il n'y a pas les moyens il n'ya pas les
personnels
il n'y a pas suffisamment points d'eau
dans les eaux dans les écoles elles
n'ont pas été conçues pour avoir des
système de rotation aussi un gros ils
sont incroyables ils sont nécessaires
compte tenu du risque de contamination
mais les locaux ne sont pas admis en
classe et donc les maires vont devoir
agir
et puisque monsieur le président m les
références guerrière moi me fait penser
au général nivelle qui en 1910 est
envoyé à la mort les troupes par vagues
entières en espérant que finalement un
assaut se réaliserait et heureusement
qu'il y avait des capitaines des
lieutenants et des sergents sur le
terrain pour éviter une case totale et
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui vous
avez des mères qui font un refus
d'obéissance
je pense au maire de stains dit moi je
voudrais pas les écoles je ne prends pas
les risques je n'ai pas les personnels
je n'ai pas les moyens c'est mettre en
danger tout le monde et vous avez des
mères qui comme la maire de paris vont
faire au mieux et donc ils préviennent
que ne seront pris à l'école que les
enfants que à partir du 13 ou 14 que
mais que ne viendront que les enfants
dont les parents et c'est bien normal
maintenant pas d'autre choix tous ceux
qui sont soignants policiers et pompiers
pour ceux qui sont absolument
nécessaires en première ligne ne que
quand on verra que ce soit des classes
maximum de 5 des personnes qui s'adapte
au mieux avec des moyens très difficile
et on ne te pas et ils sont inquiets on
va le voir
georges kuzmanovic l'exécutif qui veut
s'appuyer sur les élus locaux c'est ce
que vous avez dit mais certains y voient
l'occasion de l'état de se défausser de
ses responsabilités on va écouter
stéphane troussel il est président du
parti socialiste du conseil
départemental de la seine saint denis la
décentralisation ce n'est ni la loi de
la jungle ni le centralisme autoritaire
or l'état godillon permanence ma crainte
c'est que l'état désarmé sans remettre
collectivité mais ne soit plus garant de
l'égalité républicaine que l'état ne
soit plus garant de l'égalité
républicaine aurélie gros qu'en pensez
vous j'en pense qu'effectivement les
états doivent pas on doit pas de pester
sur les collectivités la responsabilité
de l'état effectivement sur cette
question de l'école et moi j'ai quatre
enfants dont vous imaginez que ça peut
me questionner quant à la reprise de mes
enfants à l'école ou non et
collectivités n'ont pas forcément les
moyens le personnel en fonction de la
taille des collectivités si je regarde
le coudray-montceaux 5000 habitants il
est bien qu'en termes personnels en
terme de budget en termes d'adaptation
population donc dans cette course pour
être certains que nos enfants pitt
surplomb de l'école dans des conditions
sanitaires qui correspondent aux
demandes de l'état c'est très compliqué
est aujourd'hui clairement cette marge
de manoeuvre qu'a laissé le gouvernement
notamment sur la zone rouge qui laisse
le son au maire de oui ou non ré ouvrir
l'école puisque c'est cela la réponse à
lui mais je pense qu'elle est
essentielle nous n'avons pas la même
façon le procurer dans une petite
commune que dans une grosse commune nous
n'avons pas les mêmes soutiens je vous
rejoins genre sur le fait de dire que
les collectivités n'étaient pas toutes
les responsabilités à prendre et que le
fait qu'on n'ait pas des moyens égaux
dans certaines communes et des écoles
égal dans certaines communes on ne
puisse pas adapté les mêmes les mêmes
réponses aux parents mais effectivement
on sait aussi que l'économie doit
reprendre que les français doivent
retourner au travail et cette solution
réouverture d'école puisque vous la
comparez aux pays européens tels que
l'espagne ou l'italie est effectivement
l'espagne ou l'italie record que leur
ouverture t elle ce que beaucoup de
français aussi attendait en france mais
on n'a pas non plus les mêmes conditions
climatiques en espagne ou en italie en
france et vont pas la même carte de
l'épidémie je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut non pas avoir un état qui décide
seul ou qui déleste sont les communes
parce que c'est comme ça on se cale
cochon c'est perçu par tout le monde
quel que soit le parti politique il faut
que ce soit un travail conjoint entre
les communes et l'état et qu'on prenne
des décisions qui correspondent à nos
cas de là que je disais que il faut un
vrai lien est une vraie collaboration
tant au niveau de l'état que des
collectivités territoriales et pourquoi
cette crise démontré que la
décentralisation
on est le rôle des communes étaient
essentielles en france à dire que les
territoires ego un angle de coordination
de ces régions des initiatives un petit
peu partout vous parliez de l'école des
masques il y a aussi les traitements à
la chloroquine qui ont été ses
massivement à marseille la question des
tests aussi il y en a eu plus dans
certaines régions que d'autres
finalement georges kuzmanovic est ce
qu'il n'ya pas là aussi des velléités
électorale on est à l'entre-deux tours
des municipales et bientôt il y aura les
départementales et régionales
est-ce que c'est pas non plus électorale
comme démarche non je crois que ça
correspond plus à une démarche globale
de ce gouvernement c'est un gouvernement
qui a pour objectif il a montré dans les
politiques une qui l'a mise en oeuvre
avant la crise deux cas c'est l'état
nation en particulier au niveau des
écoles et les universités
en supprimant le bac au niveau national
et en divisant les régions en est un
plus cette ligne en national qui a fait
la france depuis la révolution française
donc cette situation de chaos parce que
cette situation de chaos où
malheureusement dans laquelle nous
sommes et ce n'est pas le seul pays où
on aura des écoles qui vont ouvrir
d'autres qui vont rouvrir à moitié de
qui rouvre et aux tiers qui vont ouvrir
une semaine qui fermait va faire
quelques elle qu'elle suit de fin
d'année auront nous en commun en france
bon c'est tragique pour beaucoup de gens
et mais je pense que ça arrange ce
gouvernant qui souhaitent cela je suis
en ce moment avec l'une de mes trois
filles qui rentre en seconde dans les
inscriptions affelnet qui est qu un truc
complètement délirant qui a été inventé
par ce par ce gouvernement comme par
coups reçus et on découvre des choses
aussi rocambolesque que le choix du
lycée sera annoncé en fin d'année
l'algorithme aura choisi on va répartir
les enfants le 1er juillet et à partir
du 2
juillet jusqu'au 2 juillet à midi à part
sur les ordinateurs ou deux jours de
plus en présentiel
il faudra aller s'inscrire dans les
lycées en pleine crise hier qu' on va
voir des dizaines et dizaines soit des
centaines de parents et d'enfants qui
vont devoir se précipiter pour
s'inscrire
un exemple des multiples choses
auxquelles ce gouvernement n'a pas pensé
mais je pense qu'ils s'en rendent en
compte une semaine avant et que ça fera
un nouveau une nouvelle de cacophonie
encore une fois c'est parce que ces gens
là ne gouverne pas il ne souhaite pas
gouverner ce sont des gens qui ont
sabordé l'état saborder la force de
l'état en france saborder la nation il
faut quand même rappeler parce que on
dit qu'ils sont pas responsables mais je
rappellerai que monsieur verront
l'actuel ministre de la santé monsieur
salomon actuel directeur de la santé en
france où monsieur natale étaient tous
membres des cabinets de madame touraine
qui qui a sabordé nos systèmes de de
défense en particulier les réserves de
masques les les
les ai cru ce qui permet de réagir dans
ce genre de situations d'urgence
monsieur macron était quand même
conseiller de françois hollande au
moment où tout ça c'est fait puis
ministre de l'économie c'est eux qui ont
sabordé la cette résilience général que
nous devrions avoir que commencer contre
ce que je mène au vif c'est ce que va
dire c'est ce que nous avons toujours
dit il devant rendre des comptes
mais on se retrouve dans cette situation
incroyable où nous sommes paralysés les
écoles sont paralysées et l'économie est
paralysée parce que nous avons dû
appliquer le l'option ultime préconisée
par l' oms de confinement et général de
toute la population
parce que nous n'avons nous n'avons pas
ces brigades en avance nous n'avons pas
réservé de masse nous n'aurons pas de
systèmes industriels
c'est surtout ça la question ya pas
assez d en rire s est pas que il n'
avait pas que ça en fait c'est un calcul
qui était très mal fait au début par
certains journalistes
il ya un écart au début de la crise
entre l'allemagne et la france qui à
l'appel de 10%
sachant que l'allemagne à 83 millions
d'habitants par contre eux ils ont un
système industriel qu'ils ont conservé
en propre parce qu'ils ont une loi qui
empêche toute vente d'entreprises
industrielles
il appuie sur un bouton et en deux
semaines ils ont transmis leur
aspirateur nouveaux donc il transforme
très facilement aux délits
qui ne sont pas des lits en réanimation
en lits de réanimation ils peuvent
lancer beaucoup plus facilement les
tests et le résultat des courses ils ont
confiné beaucoup beaucoup moins on le
voit taïwan on l'a vu à singapour on l'a
vu encore et elle revient sur la
question des mères si vous le voulez
bien georges kuzmanovic les mails les
jours encore une fois les maires vont se
retrouver avec des moyens réduits pour
les mères certaines villes ont plus de
moyens mais néanmoins ils n'ont pas les
îles et tous les moyens de l'état pour
faire face à cette crise et je vous
rappelle une chose monsieur macron n'est
pas responsable pénalement
monsieur le premier ministre les
messieurs philippe ainsi que les maires
me sens comme dans un pays où les filles
je pense que justement il est question
de la responsabilité pénale des mères
c'est ce qu'ils craignent
on va écouter françois baroin qui a
réclamé une protection juridique
supplémentaire mais il n'a pas
visiblement été entendu ce matin lorsque
la halle à la loi sur la luge en
sanitaire a été prolongée de deux mois
écoutez le les maires ne veulent pas
être des kamikazes sur une
responsabilité qui n'est pas la leur au
départ lorsqu'ils n'auront pas la
possibilité soit techniques soient
matériels de mettre en oeuvre les
mesures de déconfinement le risque c'est
d'avoir beaucoup d'écoles qui ne
pourront pas rouvrir pas parce que les
mères fuir leurs responsabilités mais
parce qu'ils ne pourraient pas l'exercer
aurélie gros est-ce qu'il faut insérer
dans ce texte justement une protection
juridique christophe castaner l'a dit ce
matin que c'était déjà le cas qu'ils
étaient déjà suffisamment protégé c'est
votre sentiment
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'effectivement
elle vient alors préciser les choses au
niveau des populations passons
aujourd'hui la responsabilité du maire
seront engagées quant aux mesures qu'il
mettra en place au défilement et pour
cette notamment réouverture des écoles
est clairement je le disais tout à
l'heure une taille d'environ 10 de
femmes et habitants allaient tous les
mêmes moyens exil de 50000 habitants et
encore moins que le pari que ou que
d'autres que marseille d'ailleurs avoue
que d'autres vite ch donc aujourd'hui
on est confronté à des ouvertures
partielles dire que tout le monde dans
le discours de jean teulé lancker tous
les parents d'élèves ont l'impression
que les primaires pour réouvrir dans
leur intégralité le 12 mai donc le 11
mai pour les professeurs et le mec pour
les enfants or ce n'est pas possible et
on va s'en trouver avec des groupes e
div élèves maximum par place avec des
classes sûrement de celle de cp plus
grande section de maternelle des
moyennes sections des petites sections
de matam qui ne résout pas parce que
nous n'aurons pas les moyens avec des
enfants des cantines où on les attend on
est dans l'impossibilité de ré vous
l'avez cantine par rapport aux gestes
barrière avec ses enfants
donc aujourd'hui on est dans un modèle
qui ne correspond pas à ce que avoir vu
le gouvernement et monsieur lancker est
tout simplement parce que on ne s'est
pas adapté à la vision qu'avaient les
connectivités du terrain aujourd'hui il
faut écouter les élus locaux qui
connaissent leurs amis près il connaît
leur ville qui connaît leurs enfants
leurs possibilités d'action et de
réouverture est clairement si les maires
de son parent protéger de toute manière
on aura des remontées citoyenne et l'or
qui ne sont pas de la responsabilité des
maires dont c'est pour ça que je parle
bien de 2,7 de ce mariage que des
utilités et a en tout cas la seule vraie
collaboration qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
mener
ils n'ont pas les bons les maires se
sentit tenez vous reprenez vos écoles
vous avez ce virus avec et on parle
combourg et vous pourrez vrai comme vous
tous mais surtout dans le cas vous
disais tout à l'heure on est quand même
encore en période électorale dans
certaines villes et ça peut être un
enjeu électoral qui n'est absolument pas
normal on ne gère pas une crise comme
celle là avec un enjeu électoral
derrière donc je pense que ces unions
nationales que les maires quelles que
soient leurs partis politiques doivent
être entendus et qu'aujourd'hui on doit
trouver un système qui convienne et qui
ne prennent pas d'eux qu'ils ne fassent
pas compte de rick à nos enfants
clairement
quand moi je vois la situation sur ma
copie on va avoir quoi pour chaque élève
neuf jours de cours jusqu'à fin juin
ces neuf jours de cours oui donc c'est
bon les parents au travail aurélie gros
seins c'est là toute la question quand
même travail remettent les paroles de au
travail il faut bien qu'ils comprennent
aussi que ça va être une reprise de
travail la mi temps ça va pas être une
reprise de travail à temps complet et
leurs enfants sont à l'école deux jours
par semaine lundi mardi pas le jeudi et
vendredi
donc oui il reste une minute je vous
donne le mot de la fin georges kiejman
au but mais je prendrai le cas des
parents certains ne sont pas cadrées
peuvent pas continuer un travail en
télétravail de la maison et vont se
retrouver devant des choix cornéliens
soit prendre des risques pour leurs
enfants soient perdre leur travail
puisque à partir du 11 mai certains
seront pourront être enjoint par
l'entreprise puisqu'il y aura des
compliments à travailler même s'ils ne
sont pas de première ligne aura une
égalité qui a déjà véritable des classes
qui a été annoncé par le pain monsieur
le premier ministre à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale a dit ce qu'ils
peuvent continuer télétravail pourront
rester deux trois semaines de plus à la
maison ça veut dire garder leurs enfants
auront droit de ne pas aller travailler
c'est la fin de ce débat malheureusement
merci beaucoup auraient des gros et
merci à vrai georges kiejman riches
d'avoir participé à ce face à face
politique
merci à vous de votre fidélité rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]